here with more fox news contributor
laura trump and nationally syndicated
radio host daniel laura trump i start
with you i always say you know what what
if your father-in-law were president and
he abandoned americans behind enemy
lines
if he had to beg opec for the lifeblood
of our economy oil
give putin a waiver and fire american
oil workers and energy workers kill
children in a drone strike and say oops
that's about it i understand pain too
open borders
in the middle of a pandemic inflation
and you know i'm just touching the
surface here
you know there would be a very different
reaction in the media and elsewhere
thoughts
yeah
it's it's complete hypocrisy we know
we've seen it uh firsthand throughout
the course of my father-in-law's
administration and now you compare that
to the biden administration and you're
right it hasn't been enough that the
first order of business for joe biden
and the democrats was killing the xl
keystone pipeline putting thousands of
energy workers out of a job it hasn't
been enough that they're paying people
to stay home from work there are small
businesses out there that can't even run
and can't even open now because they
can't find workers to work after the
pandemic this is what the biden
administration is doing it hasn't been
enough that you're right we have
americans behind enemy lines 13 dead
individuals we also
have been giving uh us military
equipment now 83 billion dollars of it
to terrorist organizations now we have
an open border now we have millions of
people flowing in and we are paying on
taxpayer dime to send them all over the
country on planes and buses in case you
haven't noticed america joe biden kamala
harris and the democrats do not care
about you they do not care about
squandering your taxpayer money they do
not care about your livelihood they do
not care about your constitutional
rights and your civil liberties they
care about themselves they care about
remaining in power the media has been
covering up for them and now americans
are outraged i can't wait for 2022 and
2024. dana i don't like being lied to
mayorkus is lying to us we only got a 90
seconds but i want you to really hone in
on that
yeah no mayorkis has lied to us he needs
to step down but sean i got to say
something that piggybacks right on what
laura said and please oh my gosh i miss
your father-in-law for the love uh i
miss i miss all of it i miss the press
conferences and i miss being informed
daily about what my administration was
doing sean the biden harris
administration could send planes for
people crossing the border illegally and
they couldn't send them for american
allies in kabul they couldn't send them
for the sivs they couldn't send them for
the informants and for the translators
but they'll send them for people who are
illegally entering at the border that's
what this administration's priority is
they've lied people have died the
border's open and we need more we need
to do more to contain it look if they
can pick and choose what federal laws
they're going to follow then by god i
think the governor of texas can pick and
choose what federal laws he's going to
follow we've had enough
well said and i'll tell you i never
thought any of this could happen we're
only eight months in and on top of it i
don't even think he knows what day it is
thank you both hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else